there have been no passenger flights at
east midlands airport since
early february the departure board is
blank
the check-in desks empty safe for
essential maintenance
paul trajar has worked here for 12 years
he's calibrating the luggage weighing
scales
hoping they'll soon be logging the bags
of returning travelers
we desperately desperately need
passengers back in the building you know
to keep keep the economy working and
keep you know keep the airport alive
the government is considering reducing
air passenger duty on internal flights
to make fares cheaper and improve
connectivity around the uk
you pay less tax if you're flying to say
london to barcelona than you do if
you're flying london to
edinburgh and which and back on the
return journey which is a
somewhat bizarre situation the aviation
industry welcomes anything to get planes
taking off
good news for uh regional connectivity
in the uk it's good for
uh the uk aviation sector that's had a
really torrid time
since uh kovid hit 12 months ago
but airports present the government with
a dilemma
this is what green campaigners want to
see
nobody is flying but the government has
to balance the urgent need to get the
economy back on its feet
with its long-term climate change goals
the uk has a legally binding target to
reach net zero emissions by 2050.
last year the government pledged to
reduce emissions by at least
68 percent by 2030 compared to 1990
levels
more than a third of the uk's emissions
come from transport
including domestic air travel the
government has faced recent criticism
for failing to intervene
over plans for a new coal mine along
with frustration
over a lack of policies to reduce
emissions in last week's budget
the climate stuff just seems to go out
of the window
in favor of the short-term economic or
political interests
and we really haven't got time to keep
doing that we've not got
many many years to play with and it's
about time the government started to
live up to its own rhetoric
and take some of those crunchy decisions
filling the empty car parks with getaway
travellers will be
good for the economy but it doesn't fit
in with the prime minister's mantra
to build back green after the pandemic
lisa holland sky news east midlands
airport